After first finding American fame on the goofy
'90s sitcom Two Guys, a Girl and a Pizza Place,
Ryan Reynolds moved on to play leading roles
in multiple romantic comedies as well as action
flicks like Blade: Trinity, Green Lantern,
and—of course—Deadpool, the role he was
born to play.
Reynolds always brings a playful edge and
sharp sense of humor to his roles, which can
lead to a lot of extra footage and hilarious
outtakes.
Here are some of Ryan Reynolds' best bloopers.
Deadpool
With Deadpool, Hollywood finally figured out
what to do with Ryan Reynolds.
The fictional character blended so seamlessly
with Reynolds' real-life sense of humor that
the movie relied heavily on Reynolds' improvisation.
"It's very ice to see you.
Schwarzenegger."
However, only one take of a scene can make
the final cut, meaning there's a lot of Deadpool
outtake footage.
Before Wade Wilson becomes Deadpool, he submits
to some highly questionable medical experimentation.
He keeps his spirits up by making fun of his
captors, which gives Reynolds a chance to
rattle off different insults.
"You're gonna leave me all alone here with
Henry Winkler.
You're gonna leave me alone with 'heyyyy you
guys!'
You're gonna leave me all alone here with
Chris Angel Mind Freak"
Then there's this scene, where Deadpool shows
up at the X-Men mansion and talks about the
joys of joining the team.
"Yeah that's right I can't wait to join the
gang.
I'll give Beast a nice little belly rub it's
gonna be great."
Blade: Trinity
What few comic moments there are in the dark
and violent conclusion to Wesley Snipes' vampire
hunter trilogy come courtesy of Ryan Reynolds,
even though Blade himself ignores most of
those jokes.
In this blooper, director David S. Goyer let
Reynolds riff in character, describing his
character's musical tastes in the process.
"Me?
I'm more of a Kenny G fan myself you know?
Early stuff though.
before he sold out."
"Me, I'm more of a Clay Aiken fan.
People say I look like him."
"Me, I'm more of a Don Johnson fan, most people
don't know that he recorded an album."
The Proposal
This 2009 rom-com starred three of Hollywood's
most well-liked actors: Sandra Bullock, Betty
White, and Ryan Reynolds.
In one of the scenes, they all get together
for a group hug, which leads to one of the
best bloopers from the movie.
"Still rolling!"
"My nipple, she's got my nipple!"
Honestly, we can't tell if Reynolds is making
fun of Betty White's height, or if White actually
tried to take a bite out of him.
Either way, at least they didn't start kissing.
Nope, Reynolds saved all that loving for the
dog.
The Hitman's Bodyguard
Regardless of your religion, nuns are generally
regarded as people you don't mess with.
So of course, that's what Ryan Reynolds does.
In one scene for The Hitman's Bodyguard, Reynolds
is in a bus with a bunch of clapping nuns.
He waits for a quiet moment and launches a
clap attack on the one sitting right next
to him.
The Change-Up
In this blooper from the body switch movie
The Change-Up, Reynolds reacts quickly when
he can't remember his lines.
He stays in character as long as he can before
admitting to costar Jason Bateman that he
has no idea what he's supposed to be doing.
"I don't feel particularly good about this."
"We're just doing a pickup?"
"No, I just had a complete brain malfunction."
"You want to reload?"
"Probably because I don't feel particularly
good about this."
Just Friends
Let's face it: Poop jokes can be pretty funny.
They're even funny on repeat—possibly even
funnier.
Case in point: this blooper from the comedy
Just Friends.
Each time Reynolds tries to say his ridiculous
line, he and costar Amy Smart just laugh harder
and harder.
"Leave?
Why would Mr. Peepee pants want to leave?
Stick around.
I'm gonna s--- myself.
I'm gonna crap my pants.
I'm gonna crap my pants!"
R.I.P.D.
It's nice to know that some actors never lose
their sense of fun while filming a movie.
As this footage from the making of R.I.P.D.
shows, Reynolds always has a blast while making
a film.
Of course, it helps that he's got some fellow
goofballs like Jeff Bridges and Kevin Bacon
to play against—and a stunt car to mess
around in.
"Everybody okay?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!